uh what what are your thoughts on the
election so far
yeah i'm look i think overall it's a
good thing
it's a good night for democrats um you
know joe biden
is gonna win the white house and he will
have you know
expanded the map a little bit with you
know picking up arizona and
you know georgia i'm still seeing some
weird stuff out of georgia and i think
we still have a shot at georgia
um but the one thing that drives me nuts
is seeing still democrats acting like
we've lost this election
even though we're going to take back the
white house and you know that if
that if donald trump were in the same
position that joe biden wore
you know right now um you know in
wisconsin
in michigan in pennsylvania you know
arizona
that he would be claiming some massive
mandate right
um and instead dems are still you know
wetting the bed and
and pointing fingers when i think that
we should
take some pride in the fact that we won
this election do you think some of that
though is like an emotional mitigation
to
to evade like a a 2016 heartbreak and
be able to rejoice uh when we actually
get a positive result
i'm not sure yeah maybe um i
i also just i also think that there was
such a misfire
in terms of the polling um in terms of
democrats confidence
in terms of like the if you watch the
cable news coverage right if you watched
msnbc
cnn you know you're obviously going to
be a little bit let down
from by these results but um
you know a lot of people got got some
things very wrong in this race and i
think that's going to be something that
we're going to have to examine
afterwards
as we're talking about this this just
happened with we
uh wisconsin officially fell for joe
biden however
that poll was somewhere between nine
points to 17 points
for joe biden um and like good
quote-unquote good
pollsters um they're obviously not good
they're terrible and this poll
this state like biden clearly won it but
by 21
000 votes like that's an essential tie
um so what i'm like my mind's blown i'm
like oh and like you know this from
working in
communication in general like being on
the campaign where how much i think the
media misses things or
like the people are on one side and like
the narratives are on this other side
um so like
if you had to guess like what why are
the polls so off like why is the
narrative
so wrong is it because they're bad
posters maybe that's it or is this like
is there's this media
fire that's fueling it where do you land
on that yeah i think
it's a combination of those two um and
look a win is a win
i i don't know yes like right
like i as my view here always was
joe biden just needs to win by one vote
in michigan pennsylvania wisconsin
i don't give a [ __ ] about a [ __ ]
mandate okay i just want to win here
um and sorry you know so sorry for my
language
but i do think that sometimes i think
that the political class
and the the political professional class
does sometimes just miss the mark on
donald trump and
does not understand his appeal and and
um
always how to how to reach his
supporters and i think that that's going
to be a story
um of this campaign too is that once
again
like in 2016 the pollsters um didn't
quite capture
you know donald trump's enduring
strength and that's one of the things
that we've seen down ballot
right is a lot of the races um that we
lost
you know senate races house races were
in tough red districts
and that you know donald trump performed
really really well and and this view
that he's like this an aberrant monster
and that no one is going to support him
just really doesn't comport with the
facts and i think that we've got to
understand that
you know he is a republican and he is
like
republicans are gonna back him and that
he's not like just
history's greatest monster and that
people are gonna you know run away from
him in droves
so so true um eric i saw your mouth
moving you're gonna say something sorry
bud
no no i was just uh nodding my head
along with with everything i was talking
about
i do um i do wanna talk about
one of your superpowers and obviously
it's something that i've been wanting to
chat with you a while about
um you know uh obviously we both worked
for candidates
um that uh ran in a very crowded primary
um and i was lying if i said i
didn't uh work towards um at least
uh your earned media capabilities and
looking at
different and emerging media uh like
podcasts and other things
um i applied you know those lessons both
to my time
for tim ryan uh as well as with andrew
yang
um uh for two reasons number one
uh it definitely seemed like it was
working and number two
um just like pete you know i got to work
with two messengers that
were comfortable uh being able to to
work in those environments
uh now you know obviously the general is
different um
and uh both candidates have collective
name id going into
the general uh and perhaps you know
obviously being more comfortable in
those controlled environments but i
think back
uh to your new york times op-ed back in
the spring
uh in terms of guidance uh for the
binding campaign and do you feel like
um you know uh embracing more of
of those strategies would have helped
more uh in helping shape
the outcome going into election night um
so i don't know
i i i don't know that i've seen enough
where i can definitively say that
i do generally think that communicating
more and being more transparent and
available
is a good thing um and being out there
more is a
generally a good thing and you know i
think we can all admit that
because of the constraints of the um
of the coronavirus of you know running
in the middle of a global pandemic
that that did sort of um uh
hold down you know biden's ability to
get out there a bit more
um and i think that they
effectively use surrogates i know pete
did over like 170
interviews on behalf of the binding
campaign which is nuts we just tallied
that up
um but i always think i and
and i'm not gonna i don't want a monday
morning quarterback i don't want to do
anything because everyone's got to run
the race but
my general advice to anyone running for
president
anyone running for any office is
to get out there more and to to be a
little bit more you know to always try
to be aggressive and visible with the
media and especially
with um you know outside of the
political bubble right and that's a good
that's something that you guys did on
the yang campaign you know i know a lot
of democrats were critical that he went
on like joe rogan but give me a break
how are you going to turn down that
audience it is massive
and that's part of the reason you know
game of thrones sunday night prime time
right in terms of numbers
exactly exactly and it's like that's i
think
that was sort of like one of your first
big moments right is when you did that
um and i think that you know sometimes
democrats can be a little bit precious
about
um how we communicate how much we
communicate
um when really what we just need to do
is just go out there and get our message
out there and i agree and and
piggybacking off of that though um you
know you were just on
uh bill maher's show which has a
marginally better reach than
yang speaks here but it's fantastic
marginally uh but um you know uh bill
asked you
uh about on the on the you know these
trump car caravans i saw one of the
scary [ __ ]
um but uh you know he mentioned why
you we didn't see these things on
democratic side you uh
said so eloquently because we're not a
[ __ ] cult which
i thought was hysterical fantastic um
but like do you feel like we need to be
is that something that's missing good
question
[Laughter]
so i've you know this is something i
think about from time to time
i've thought about um and no i i just
don't i don't think we need to be
um and there are real life consequences
to
you know the behaviors of um you know
the of the
maga people right you know you see that
that study that showed that you know
700 people who had attended trump
rallies um
you know passed away from the coven from
covid and you know that there were
thousands and thousands of covenant
infections that they could tie
copenhagen infections that they could
tie back to those rallies
um but no i do think that
passion is a good thing though and that
that is something that we could probably
that we should always work toward and
and um in our politics but i don't think
that we need to become like
a cult there's probably some good middle
ground um i also just don't know that
this was the election
cycle for that sort of attitude among
you know
among democrats right i just think a lot
of this ended up coming down to
um joe biden being someone that people
were comfortable with he's a
uh and someone that they trusted enough
to sort of
lead us through the fallout of the trump
presidency
um i don't think that someone like a
bernie sanders who definitely does have
a lot more of that cult of personality
um i don't think we would be sitting
here talking about a win
if he had been the nominee even though
he's he inspires a lot stronger feelings
what would you what would you say and
get the map obviously and how
how seemingly divided things look what
would be
you know an early great public-facing
opportunity
uh for the blind transition to look at
as they're trying to
you know bridge the divide and bring the
country back together after what
will seemingly be not a very easy
transition
to say that right i think it's i think
it's an opportunity to go
big um and this is
really an opportunity to show
to be the opposite of donald trump to be
the opposite sort of of
the gop generally right um
donald trump has been very divisive the
republicans
in the senate who are you know likely
going to just continue to
do what they've been doing for the last
bunch of years are going to be very
divisive and partisan and so i think um
it's incumbent upon biden to sort of set
the stage
that um uh that he's going to try to
work in good faith try to bridge the
divide
and i think he's got to just try to do
that sort of you know
to have that sort of palette changer of
a moment um i don't think it makes sense
to come out guns of blazing being
super partisan like we're gonna you know
ram all this stuff down your throat i
think he's gotta
try to strike um uh a more you know a
more positive
unifying message at the beginning and
find him in a a powerful symbolic way to
do that
what do you guys think
andrew said something really interesting
a while back um
and he said joe biden becomes a really
interesting figure because of the lane
he's in no matter what he says it
becomes a new normal or at least
normal for the democrats and so if biden
and we joke if biden came out for cash
fleet for universal basic income if he
comes out for
a version of medicare for all or at
least a better
government health care option um or
anything
climate like his like climate change
plan is pretty aggressive um
like so like if he does that that
becomes
way more normalized you know than if
bernie ever did it
sure yeah i also think and i think he's
got to go on the econ
like i just think right now is i climate
change is so important but he's got to
really
i think this is the time to really push
through sort of more of an economic
message
agreed i agree the way of employing
empathy will be
uh greeted positively overall um right
and i think the things that he was so
famously remembered for
during his obama years will have a
greater display once he gets to move
out of this campaign mode and i think
that's what people forget
and i think that's what his bread and
butter truly is so
um i think some of his natural
capabilities will help play a role in
how he helps
you know bring the country together in
some respects yeah no i agree with that